Every family has a Sunja in their life.
That one person
who set the foundation
for who you are now.
The Sunja of my life is my mother.
My grandmother.
Mother.
My grandfather.
My mom and dad.
My previous generation.
They all sacrificed
for the second generation.
My mom's done so much for the family.
She's put everyone first,
before herself.
[My mother's] so strong and lovely...
And somehow I get a lump in my throat
just thinking of her.
My grandmother is around Sunja's age.
Whenever I visited her,
she used to tell me stories
about the things she had to go through.
She's sacrificed a lot.
I personally wanted to portray
my grandmother
and all the women from her generation.
Papa!
I think about...
Who are the people
that came before me,
but without them,
I would not be who I am now?
I hope this show prompts
similar curiosity in viewers.
I think when people watch this show,
it will be so inevitable.
Like, "I know Sunja."
[Music playing]